ça fait maintenant une semaine que le
Québec livre bataille assez grands feux
de forêt qui menacent plusieurs
communautés parlons du bilan du jour on
compte plus de 13500 personnes évacuées
à l'heure actuelle il y a 132 feux qui
sont toujours en activité les plus
préoccupants sont ceux de chez bougamou
de Lebel sur Quévillon et de normes
métal mais grâce à l'aide des pompiers
les feux n'ont pas beaucoup progressé
vers les zones les plus critiques pour
ce qui est maintenant de la qualité de
l'air on peut dire que ça s'améliore
quand même dans le sud de la province il
y a quand même des avertissements de
smog qui demeurent en vigueur
particulièrement pour les États-Unis et
regardez cette une du New York pause qui
blâme le Canada pour la fumée qui
remonte jusqu'aux États-Unis mais de
retour chez nous au Québec le premier
ministre le goût a tenu aujourd'hui à se
faire rassurant lors de sa mise à jour
quotidienne il a reconnu quand même que
ça va prendre de la patience on l'écoute
les gens là savent feu sont confiants
que ça va rester stable au moins pour
les deux prochains jours même
malheureusement on pense que c'est peu
probable que les gens puissent retourner
à la maison avant mardi là je répète les
prévisions sont toujours les mêmes donc
on prévoit pas de pluie abondante avant
lundi soir prochain je dis merci aussi
au Québec pour votre patience puis c'est
quand même exceptionnel compte tenu de
l'intensité des feux pour l'instant
aucune perte de vie aucun blessé grave
c'est ça qui est le plus important donc
continuez d'être prudent
dans les personnes les plus vulnérables
ont dû rester à l'extérieur à cause de
la qualité de l'air il y a eu un certain
malentendus hier et on a entendu le
Premier ministre le goût essayer de
remettre les pendules à l'heure si on
veut sur ce dossier là ça touche la
communauté à mississini ce qu'on ne
comprenait hier du point de presse de
Monsieur Lebeau il disait il y en a
d'évacuation de cette communauté mais le
grand chef monsieur petawa Bano lui a
dit non nous on évacue pas ici puis
c'est pas le Premier ministre le goût
qui va nous dire d'évacuer qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette histoire-là
en fait la police pendant 26 ans je dois
vous dire que ça arrive sur le terrain
quand on a des autorités locales avec un
message local qui avait été entendu
entre le chef petawabano que je connais
bien en passant que je lui parle
plusieurs fois par jour il est lui-même
exposé et qu'on parle le même langage et
hier avec les autorités locales la
subsfeuse c'est-à-dire que c'était
correct qui pouvait rester sur place
cependant une crainte qu'on a eu hier
parce que ça change rapidement
d'habitude on dit on fait un bilan à
demi-journée mais là je vous dirais que
c'est même aux heures que ça change on
craignait pour la route d'accès pour
vous allez comprendre que si cette route
devenait praticable ça devenait très
problématique pour les gens de
mysticiens le chef en état de d'accord
alors cette écologie cette érection
aujourd'hui le chef petawabano a envoyé
un communiqué de presse lui aussi disant
qu'on travaille ensemble on veut tous la
même chose on veut que ça se passe bien
il y a pas de chicane de juridiction
quoi que ce soit tout se passe vraiment
bien donc on parle pas d'une résistance
à un ordre d'évacuation je comprends
bien non du tout ça se passe très très
bien puis le Dieu lui-même la dernière
chose qu'il veut c'est que les gens de
sa communauté soient dans le trouble
alors Dr il y a des gens qui ont déjà
commencé à quitter et encourager les
gens qui avaient des mobilités réduites
des gens qui étaient plus vulnérables à
quitter c'est plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui ont quitté la communauté
le reste demain sur place pourquoi parce
qu'avec la soupe feu avec les autorités
locales ils ont établi qu'il y a un
point un point de rupture qu'on me
rappeler un marquant et à partir du
moment où le feu va se rendre à cet
endroit là ils vont devoir évacuer mais
je dirais que ces revues aux âges
parlaient au chef avant d'embarqué en
Inde avec vous ça se passe bien mais les
gens sont toujours sur le qui vivent
c'est pas le fun c'est pas c'est pas
plaisant pour les autres non c'est sûr
puis on parle de communauté souvent très
très éloignés vous l'avez dit comme dans
ce cas-ci c'est seulement une seule
route de quelle façon vous communiste
vous les appuyez
en gardant le lien constamment avec avec
les communautés en comprenant quelles
sont leurs besoins et ce qui est de
compliqué quand on parle de communauté
autochtone c'est que normalement ils
vont se référer à service autochtone
Canada étant donné qu'on parle de terre
de réserve c'est le fédéral qui leur
premier lien cependant on comprend bien
qu'en temps de crise donc on met ça de
côté on travaille ensemble aujourd'hui
je suis allé rencontrer les gens
exposités parce qu'il y a plusieurs
centaines de personnes de la communauté
de western qui ont été évacuées à cause
entre autres de la fumée et de l'accès
de la route 113 où on avait peur de
perdre cet excellent les gens qui ont dû
quitter hier en plein milieu de la
soirée même de la nuit 200 personnes qui
ont accueillies ici à Québec je les
remercier les gens de la ville de Québec
les accueillent et la communauté
c'est vraiment beau de voir Madame
drelet Le Devoir
la solidarité devant l'accueil des
Québécois c'est le cas présentement
aussi au Lac St-Jean on peut penser à
Chicoutimi à Roberval qui accueille la
communauté de djibougomo et les
commentaires que je reçois là c'est ils
sont très bien accueillis on a plusieurs
Québécois qui plusieurs personnes qui
ont levé la main disait moi mon chalet
disponible j'ai des denrées que les gens
viennent chez moi je pense que tout le
monde veut s'entraider alors oui c'est
des moments qui sont difficiles mais ce
qui est rassurant c'est que souvent on
voit le plus beau de l'humain dans ces
cas-là ça fait du bien effectivement de
voir ça cette solidarité
parlez-nous un peu des échos que vous
avez justement de ces citoyens des
Premières nations qui ont rapport on le
sait privilégié avec la nature mais
c'est leur territoire en ce moment qui
est en péril qu'ils doivent quitter ils
ont un lien privilégié comment ça se vit
pour eux le voir ses feux de forêt
ravagé ces terres
c'est aussi le regard de manger et je
dis souvent quand on parle on parle des
Premières nations des Inuits avec les
changements climatiques ce sont les
premiers témoins de ces changements moi
quand je me rends on navique et on voit
les changements le père Gilson qui
dégèle qui causent en trop des problèmes
éthiques avec les maisons qu'on a bâti
là-bas on peut on peut comprendre que
ces gens-là le voient rapidement les
changements climatiques et présentement
sur le terrain lorsque des forêts qui
brûlent comme ça ben c'est un enjeu
direct pour eux pour le garde-manger
parce qu'ils ont l'habitude d'aller à la
chasse à la pêche alors c'est de c'est
des gros impacts étant toujours dit que
j'étais de passage exposité et les gens
les plus âgés qui étaient déplacés sur
place une de leurs questions
c'est-à-dire comment votre capable de
manger avec nos habitudes habituelles
c'est-à-dire de faire un feu de faire
griller une noix moutarde comment on
veut le faire comme on fait d'habitude
alors c'est des grands changements
grands bouleversements pour ces gens-là
comme tout les Québécois qui ont dû
quitter leur communauté sans savoir
quand est-ce qu'on est de retour alors
d'avoir des des personnes qui sont là
pour les soutenir et quand vous me
demandez quel est mon rôle mon côté des
relations avec les programmations les
inouïe mais c'est de s'assurer que
lorsque les gens comme ça sont déplacés
qui sont accueillis dans un dans un
environnement qui est qui est
sécuritaire pour eux qui est donc on les
comprend on comprend la culture ici
d'avoir Wanda qui s'est joint la ville
de Québec pour travailler ensemble c'est
un très bel exemple ça se passe très
bien on m'a dit que vous avez passé de
pompiers vous oui
j'ai bien aimé les uniformes on dirait
que la misère à choisir des vêtements
alors j'étais policier pompier militaire
des gens n'ont pas comment comment vous
voyez ça parce que tout le monde
souligne le travail absolument
remarquable des pompiers de la soupe feu
les gens de l'armée qui ont une
formation très très rapide et mettant
tous ses renforts qui viennent il y a
des Français qui viennent d'arriver pour
prêter mains pas comment vous le
qualifiez ce travail là ce qui sont en
train de faire aujourd'hui à la lumière
de votre expérience
vous venez de parler des policiers des
pompiers des militants on peut parler
des paramédiques aussi qui font un
travail qui est incroyable sur le
terrain parce que quand on pense au
Paradis on pense souvent au transport
mais c'est aussi donner des soins de
première ligne alors un travail je vais
leur dire chapeau chapeau lorsqu'on
parle de pompiers moi j'étais pompier
temporaire dans une municipalité alors
la formation que j'avais était vraiment
fait de bâtiment et c'est pour ça qu'on
dit aussi lorsque des pompiers qui
lèvent vraiment dire on va être
disponible on veut donner un coup de
main ça prend une formation qui est
approprié parce que c'est pas le combat
de feu comme j'ai pu connaître dans des
résidences ou les feux que j'ai pu
combattre on y va vraiment avec une
approche qui est différente souvent ce
qu'on va faire c'est enlever le
combustible de faire en sorte de soit
d'abattre des arbres ou même de brûler
les arbres relever du combustible
honnêtement comme pompier moi j'ai
jamais allumé de feu alors c'est
vraiment une formation qui est
différente mais le travail soit un
travail qui est dur c'est des heures
c'est très physique alors on était avec
eux de tout cœur et heureux de voir que
de la relève que des gens qui sont sur
le terrain même des soins qui ont
accepté de prendre cette formation là
accélérée deux journées qui leur
permettent de donner un coup de main on
a besoin de bras mais aussi la capacité
d'accueil parce que d'avoir demain matin
10200 300 nouvelles personnes qui se
présentent faut de la supervision
surtout pas les envoyer dans une
situation qui est dangereuse je vous le
dis le vent peut tourner rapidement et
on le vécu autour de mysticisme ça
tournait dans le bon sens mais à
l'inverse ça peut faire en sorte que des
gens soient dans une situation très
dangereuse alors chapeau c'est pas un
travail qui est facile et je fais appel
maintenant à une autre de vos
expériences elle dans ses policier parce
qu'on apprend cet après-midi il a
évacuation préventive à la prison d'Amos
même si la prison ne fait pas l'objet
d'une menace imminente c'est vraiment de
façon préventive alors on déplace cette
idée tenue on le fait par convoi on les
transports je pense vers Montréal que
genre de défi ça représente ça tout un
défi logistique et les gens vont se
demander pourquoi pourquoi déplacer des
détenus avant de déplacer la population
générale vous allez comprendre que les
enjeux logistiques sont vraiment très
différents c'est pas des gens qui vont
se déplacer par eux-mêmes on comprend
quand ils sont détenus les deux choses
qu'on veut c'est leur donner les clés
d'un véhicules alors on doit organiser
un déplacement logistique hautement
sécuritaire ça va prendre du temps et
c'est pour ça que je pense que la bonne
décision à prendre de l'organiser à
l'avance comme ça faut pas se retrouver
dans un délai de trois quatre cinq
heures pour déplacer des gens de cette
façon là vous pouvez vous imaginer que
ça promener de grands enjeux de sécurité
alors c'est tout un défi un défi
logistique je peux vous donner un
parallèle lorsque j'étais à Montréal on
voulait déplacer seulement les archives
je parle même pas des nuls les archives
qu'on avait au niveau du renseignement
et c'est un défi logistique de tout
moment parce que ça me prenait de la
sécurité une autre sécurité de bien
planifier alors je vois le parallèle
facilement avec des détenus on doit
l'organiser à l'avance pour pas que ça
va prendre la dernière minute ça c'est
clair bon alors on va vous en avez plein
les bras et vos collègues aussi à
Monsieur Lafrenière une équipe en
passant même deux lettres avec l'équipe
avec tous les gens qui sont sur le
terrain je remercie mes collègues très
beau quand même beaucoup pour l'entrevue
monsieur lafonnière c'est à vous pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI